At first, it's very bright.
But then, as your eyes adjust to the light,
you start to piece together
your surroundings.
The moving blobs above you, you realize,
are masked faces.
And they've got their
hands inside your body.
Okay, who messed up?
You can't run,
you can't scream,
luckily, you can't feel.
But still, you have to watch...
This is 'What If,'
and here's what happens
if you wake up during surgery.
The odds of you waking up
during surgery are about 1 in 19,000.
That might not sound like a lot but,
considering that doctors perform
over 130,000 inpatient surgeries
daily in the U.S. alone,
it's close to 7 people every day.
When it does happen, it's usually painless,
and you're usually back under in 5 minutes.
But that's not to say there
haven't been some horror stories.
In a study of people who've
experienced anesthesia awareness,
18% reported feeling pain,
and some even developed
post traumatic symptoms
like increased stress,
nightmares, and flashbacks.
Before any surgery, an anesthesiologist
will review your medical history,
and ask you about your habits
and your lifestyle.
Everyone reacts differently to anesthetics,
so, it's the anesthesiologist's job
to figure out a dose that will keep
you unconsious during surgery,
without inhibiting any of
your critical life functions.
As you're counting down,
getting heavier, getting sleepier, getting...
Up soon?
What? Is it morning already?
Where am I?
Anesthesia alertness can
play out in different ways.
It usually involves complications
with the sedative, the paralytic, or both.
If the paralytic wears off,
but the sedative doesn't.
You'll remain unconsious,
but your body might still move.
Anesthetists are normally
quick to pick up on this,
and will immediately fix the problem
by adding more paralytic agent.
Then there's the problem of both the
sedative and the paralytic wearing off.
This is also easy to catch, because
the patient might try to speak or sit up.
But again, doctors will have you
back under in less than five minutes.
Perhaps the most traumatic outcome
is if the sedative wears off,
but the paralytic doesn't.
In this scenario, you can wake up
during surgery, and you might even feel it.
But with the paralytic agent
working as it's supposed to,
you can't communicate that you're awake.
While that scenario is particularly rare,
it's happened enough times to
inspire one too many movie ideas.
But, if you're scared it could happen to you,
there are ways to further reduce
your risk of anesthesia alertness.
It's always important have
up-to-date medical records,
and to follow your doctor's instructions
carefully before surgery.
For bonus points, you can cut back
on alcohol and tobacco,
since, heavy drinking and smoking can affect
how your body responds to anesthetic drugs.
As long as you keep
making healthy choices,
and don't let the movies
scare you too much,
then your next surgery
should go smoothly.
When you wake up
at the right time
you can thank your doctor;
and in your downtime,
you can thank, 'What If.'